[Musique]
bonjour depuis le 16 juin les députés de
la commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 auditionnent
les acteurs de la crise sanitaire monde
médical mais aussi ancien ministre et
directeur généraux de la santé tout
l'été lcp vous fait revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui celle de didier
houssin ancien directeur général de la
santé de 2005 à 2011 la travailler avec
les ministres xavier bertrand et
roselyne bachelot c'est à cette époque
qu'il avait été confronté à l'épidémie
de h1n1 dont la gestion par les
autorités avaient été jugées
disproportionnées avant d'être
réhabilité
on écoute dès à présent didier houssin
monsieur le professeur mes chers
collègues nous avons souhaité entendre
les différents directeurs généraux de
santé pour pouvoir retracer l'évolution
de l'organisation de la réponse aux
crises sanitaires
nous terminons cette série d'auditions
en recevant aujourd'hui monsieur didier
houssin messieurs professeur je vous
remercie de votre présence avant de vous
donner la parole je vais vous demander
de prêter serment
en effet l'article 6 de leur donnant du
17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnes
auditionnées par une commission denquête
de prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité
je vous invite donc à lever la main
droite est à dire je le jure je le jure
je vous remercie
je rappelle donc que cette audition et
publiques diffusées en direct est
consultable en vidéo et fera l'objet
d'un compte rendu écrit qui sera publié
monsieur vous avez la parole pour un
cours propos liminaire qui va précéder
les changes avec les parlementaires
merci merci madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames messieurs les députés donc
quelques mots pour me présenter mais
vous l'avez fait j'ai un lourd passé en
matière de risque pandémique comme vous
l'avez dit j'étais directeur général de
la santé de 2005 à 2011 et non en 2013
et en même temps délégué
interministériel à la lutte contre la
grippe aviaire
j'ai d'ailleurs évoqué dans cette cette
expérience dans un ouvrage de 2014 dont
j'offre un exemplaire à votre commission
denquête ensuite de 2011 à et 2020 j'ai
conseillé l' oms en matière de sécurité
sanitaire face aux risques
pandémique est mon rôle vis-à-vis de
kobe de 19 vous l'avez dit c'est jouer
deux niveaux le niveau de l'om est-ce
que vous avez mentionné que je ne
reprendrai pas celui de la mission qu'a
sexe non plus j'ajouterai simplement
qu'en tant que membre de l'académie
nationale de médecine j'ai assuré depuis
mars
depuis mi mars le secrétaire de la
cellule qu'ovide 19
je ne sais pas si monsieur lagarde est
là mais il sera sans doute heureux de
savoir que sa demande que l'académie
nationale de médecine joue un rôle plus
important
durant ce type de crise passe 686 181,2
du rapport de la commission denquête de
juillet 2010 a eu une suite favorable
l'occasion du comic 19 un peu tardif
peut-être mais favorable quand même mon
propos liminaire se centrera autour de
la notion de préparation au risque
pandémique avec trois approches le
regret qu'elle était critiqué en 2010 le
constat que le défaut de préparation a
eu en 2020 des conséquences graves et
l'espoir enfin que la préparation à ce
risque devienne une obligation dans
notre pays un regret d'abord impact
gestion conséquences très bien mais un
mot n'apparaît pas dans l'intitulé de
votre commission
c'est le mot préparation entre 2005 et
2009 sous la menace du virus h5n1 la
préparation de la france au risque
pandémique lien virus émergents à
transmission respiratoire a été intense
elle a conduit un travail
interministériel inédit pour développer
décliner puis perfectionnée un plan
national préparer notre société à la
continuité d'activité en situation de
pandémie s'exercer constituer des stocks
de produits de santé masques antiviraux
respirateur préparer les organisations
logistiques préparer la production d'un
vaccin et organiser l'action de l'état
en particulier avec la création de
l'eprus notamment en 2007 pour monsieur
d'or se souvient évidemment très bien en
2010 au décours de la pandémie de 2009
due au virus h1n1
moins grave que redouté au début cette
préparation a été critiqué au lieu
d'être félicités pour avoir limité le
nombre de décès nous avons été critiqués
voire trop dépenser je vous renvoie
notamment aux commission denquête devant
lesquels j'ai eu l'honneur sinon la joie
d'être convoqué là encore monsieur
lagarde et monsieur d'or s'en
souviennent dix ans ont passé
la violente critique en 2010 de cette
préparation a selon moi jouer un rôle
majeur dans l'affaiblissement en france
de la préparation au risque pandémique
affaiblissement qui s'est révélé de
façon dramatique fin janvier 2020
lorsque le ms a déclaré que kovy 19
était une urgence de santé publique de
portée internationale voilà pour le
regret un constat ensuite en dépit du
travail admirable des hospitaliers et du
civisme de la population
trente mille décès ont été déplorés à ce
jour et l'impact économique et social
est majeur notre défaut de préparation
porte une part de ses graves
conséquences
face à un virus d'autant plus dangereux
qu'il est excrété avant les signes
cliniques
c'est un point très important l'absence
de traitement et de vaccins et la rareté
des tests virologiques disponibles
imposaient de recourir aux méthodes
rustique de prévention sinon la fuite du
mois la distanciation l'hygiène des
mains est le port du masque
j'avoue avoir été sidérée d'apprendre
que le stock de masques de la france
s'était évaporé j'ai pas le parler
dissolution parce que j'ai pensé que
c'était un terme qui vous étaient
désagréables à partir de 2005 nous avons
décidé avions décidé la constitution
d'un grand stock de masques précisément
parce que nous redoutions quand je dis
nous ce sont évidemment les ministres de
la santé de l'époque j'étais directeur
général de la santé et bien sûr le
gouvernement derrière c'est lesquels se
situer ses ministres précisément parce
que nous redoutions face au virus h5n1
la terrible situation dans laquelle nous
nous sommes trouvés en 2020 face au
courant d'un virus nous estimions alors
qu'en l'absence de vaccins et de
traitements le minimum que l'état
pouvait faire pour protéger les
professionnels les plus exposés la
population était de leur donner des
masques afin de réduire le risque de
transmission du virus en 2010 en avril
2010 après la pandémie grippale due au
virus h1n1
il restait du stock de masques constitué
au prix d'efforts importants industriels
financiers logistiques en avril 2010
donc il restait un milliard de masques
chirurgicaux anti projections pour la
population et les malades soit environ
100 % du besoin alors estimé je
reviendrai là dessus si vous le
souhaitez et 700 millions de masques
ffp2 à haute capacité de filtration pour
les professionnels exposés
professionnels de santé professionnels
du secteur médico social et autres
professionnels de la sécurité
profession en activité de guichet ou
d'accueil 80 % du besoin estimé
j'insiste sur deux points le calcul du
besoin était fondé sur un certain nombre
de masques par jour une durée de 12
semaines pour la vague pandémique et sur
un calcul de la dimension de population
à couvrir par catégorie professionnelle
la doctrine concernant les masques ffp2
s'inscrivait dans un plan plus vaste
centré sur la préparation du plan de
continuité d'activité à tous les niveaux
secteur public secteur privé à partir du
document unique d'évaluation des risques
du ministère du travail qui a joué alors
un rôle très important
les masques dont devait se doter aussi
les acteurs économiques et les
collectivités territoriales
par exemple pour les éboueurs et l outil
contribuant à la continuité d'activité
mon travail de délégué interministériel
avait alors a consisté à rencontrer dans
le cadre de réunions organisées chaque
semaine tous les secteurs banque
assurance boulanger médias
agroalimentaire funéraire et cetera et
cetera pour les inciter à deux choses
préparer leur pca et acheter des masques
si notre stock de masques ne s'était pas
au évaporé on aurait peut-être pu
organiser autrement
le confinement dans le sens d'une
meilleure préservation de la continuité
d'activité en lisant le rapport du
sénateur de la jay compris qu'en 2015 ce
stock avaient commencé à se déliter en
2020 il avait fini par quasiment
s'évaporer au point de nous mettre en
situation de pénurie
comment cela est-il possible ceci est
particulièrement grave concernant les
masques ffp2 pour les soignants
car une lecture de la doctrine d'emploi
de ces masses produite par le haut
conseil de la santé publique le 1er
juillet 2011 qui la lite limiterait aux
actes les plus invasive
cette lecture me paraît discutable il me
semble qu'il fallait faire encore à ce
moment là le maximum pour protéger les
soignants exposés quel que soit leur
secteur d'activité
les masques serait-il qu'un marqueur
parmi d'autres du défaut de préparation
au risque pandémique
qu'en at il été de la mise à jour de la
planification des actions de la
coordination interministérielle de la
préparation de la continuité des
activités des exercices de
l'anticipation de la recherche
développement et la coordination
européenne et nationale des essais
cliniques
il est vrai que la france n'a pas été le
seul pays dans cette situation cela ne
peut pas être une consolation la france
était reconnu pour être un des pays les
mieux préparés
elle se retrouvait dans la même
situation que de nombreux autres pays
une situation dans laquelle il faut
subir et improvisée or et les musiciens
qui sont ici le sable improvisation ne
s'improvise pas
planification il a fallu activer le plan
pandémie grippale qui avait le mérite
d'exister mais qui datait de 2011 il
n'avait pas été mise à jour gestion de
crise alors que l'unité d'action reste
une règle de cette gestion
il a fallu attendre de longues semaines
pour qu'un centre interministériel de
crise unique gère la crise liée aux
qu'ovide 19 une préparation plus active
et la répétition des exercices dans les
années précédentes aurait peut-être
permis d'éviter cela expertises
scientifiques de façon inattendue un
paysage complexe a été créé avec
l'invention de deux conseils
scientifiques alors que notre pays
dispose et d'instances expérimenté
composé avec soin et compétente en
matière d'analysé de risques santé
publique france notre vigie notre source
de données qui a pu qui a su s'appuyer
sur des équipes de modélisation et
d'épidémiologie de qualité en matière d
expertise pour la gestion de risque avec
le haut conseil de la santé publique qui
a fait préparer la doctrine sanitaire de
gestion du risque
heureusement la qualité des membres du
conseil scientifique que vous avez je
crois
tendu a permis d'éviter que la
complexité ne se transforme en confusion
peut pas et évidemment ni et la grande
qualité de personne comme delfraissy
fontanes et li na et la dame qui les
accompagnait il a fallu cependant
attendre la mise en place de la mission
de jean castex pour que la notion
d'anticipation et de préparation
prennent enfin sa place à partir du 9
avril
un espoir enfin pour conclure un triste
espoir que l'impact sanitaire social et
économique de la pandémie de kovy 19
laisse de telles traces que l'on prenne
enfin au sérieux dans la longue durée la
préparation au risque pandémique
il faut en effet se concentrer sans
faiblir sur les risques avérés
douloureusement éprouvé en france depuis
des siècles et qui sont les plus lourds
la guerre et l'épidémie sachons trier
entre ce qui est prioritaire et ce qui
l'est moins
ne laissons pas les événements
intercurrente même s'ils sont importants
ils réclament une réponse adaptée
détourner des grandes priorités de
préparation que vu leur impact potentiel
sont la défense et la préparation risque
pandémique pour le risque de guerre nous
avons une armée elle se prépare elle
s'équipe elle s'entraîne ce devrait être
pareil pour le risque pandémique car
tout incite à se préparer à ce risque
la densification de l'espèce humaine la
densification des espèces animales
l'accroissement des interactions entre
espèces animales l'accroissement et
entre espèces humaines et espèces
animales la multiplication des échanges
de personnes et de biens par les
migrations le tourisme et le commerce
les pratiques d'élevage des animaux les
conditions de vie des êtres humains dans
les grandes villes à tous les échelons
local régional national européen plus
que tout et mondial faisons que cette
cette préparation au risque pandémique
une priorité qui dure et que l'on
organise pour résister à l'oubli yeuse
mémoire puisque j'ai l'occasion de
m'adresser aux législateurs quelques
suggestions pour conclure un une
obligation de préparation au risque
pandémique de une planification mise à
jour déclinés testés et évalués
3 une coordination interministérielle
c'est peut-être le plus important
quatre des contre-mesures quand
j'entends contre-mesures j'entends les
masques les solutions hydroalcooliques
et tout ce qui peut être éventuellement
dans les différentes hypothèses un
traitement ou un vaccin des
contre-mesures sur la responsabilité de
l'état avec un contrôle parlementaire
comme j'imagine l'exercent pour la
défense votre commission de la défense
nationale
un effort européen pour kuhn europe de
la sécurité sanitaire secret dont le
volet de préparation au risque
pandémique serait le pivot une stratégie
enfin de recherche et développement sous
contrôle de l'opex à ce propos je ne
peux pas ne pas vous alerter sur la
grave situation de la recherche en
france puisque vous allez bientôt
débattre d'une loi de programmation pour
la recherche
je veux souligner qu'il ya bien sûr des
aspects budgétaires à traiter mais il y
a surtout un besoin de simplification
extrême
l'université devrait être enfance le
coeur des activités de recherche comme
c'est le cas dans la plupart des pays
développés
il faudrait donc unifier le corps des
enseignants chercheurs et celui des
chercheurs et revoir profondément les
missions des organismes tels que le cnrs
ou l'inserm dont la création a été très
utile après la guerre mais dont la
valeur ajoutée est aujourd'hui
discutable merci de votre attention
merci beaucoup je suis passé la parole à
monsieur rapporteur merci monsieur le
professeur vous avez exercé des
responsabilités importantes vous les
avez rappelé vous venez de porter une
vision et un regard assez critique assez
sévère même sur l'impréparation qui a
marqué la gestion de cette crise et ses
conséquences terribles que vous avez que
vous avez rappelé je voudrais vous
interrogez d'abord sur vos fonctions de
président du comité d'urgence de l'om
est ce vous avez l'avantagé d'avoir
cette vision et ce recul sur ce qui
s'est passé dans notre pays d'avoir été
un acteur
à la fois dans l'épisode de grippe
aviaire dans l'épisode du virus h1n1 et
vous l'avez rappelé qu'elle quel regard
comparatif vous portez sur ce qui s'est
passé dans d'autres pays
qu'est ce qui fait que le constat le
diagnostic sévère que vous dressez s'est
produit dans notre pays par rapport à
d'autres je pense aux pays du sud est
asiatique qui ont mieux fait face à la
pandémie
et qu'est ce que vous savez qu est ce
que vous pouvez dire à notre commission
sur le la date d'information plusieurs
intervenants à votre place nous ont
indiqué qu'il y avait eu un retard dans
les prises de décision est-ce que ce
retard nous aurions pu l'éviter par
rapport aux informations notamment de l'
oms provenant de chine d'abord mais d
informations internationales dont nous
disposions donc ça c'est plutôt ce
regard et cette comparaison
internationale est un élément sur
l'information sur la datte d'information
sur la prise en compte dans d'autres
pays et ensuite je voudrais vous
interrogez vous enfin vous avez beaucoup
abordé ce sujet je crois qu'il est
essentiel en effet sur les questions de
coordination coordination
interministérielle c'est vrai qu'on a
été frappé par la multiplicité des
instances d'autres ont été créées
spécifiquement avec la crise vous posez
vos pieds le conseil scientifique on
pourrait rajouter le caire on pourrait
tous ses organes il se rajoutant à ce
qui existait déjà et qui peut avoir le
sentiment tout cas vu de l'extérieur de
créer une confusion et un manque de
pilotage successeur évoqué hier la
nécessité d'avoir maréchal de guerre à
la tête de toutes ses armes et mais au
delà de la coordination nationale entre
le chorus les cellule interministérielle
conseil scientifique etc
il y a aussi la coordination locale
la stratégie nationale qui relève de
l'état de ces autorités sanitaires mais
aussi sa déclinaison concrète sur le
terrain et là on
plus nous a été dit aussi mais je
voudrais avoir votre analyse votre
appréciation
un peu un double pilotage quelquefois
difficiles et source et improductif
entre le préfet les préfets des
départements et les ars qui ont
introduit une forme de confusion et de
questionnements sur le pilotage donc je
voulais avoir ces deux approches une
internationale et une très locale merci
monsieur le rapporteur
alors d'abord le comité d'urgence de
l'om s il est important d'avoir à
l'esprit que c'est un instrument qui qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre du règlement
sanitaire international
ce n'est pas un comité permanent c'est
un comité qui réunit par le directeur
général de l'om est ce qui est convoqué
par le directeur général de l'om est
essentiellement pour lui donner un avis
sur une question est-ce que ce qui se
passe est une urgence de santé publique
de portée internationale
car dans le cadre de ce règlement qui
est le principal traité international en
matière de santé
ça ouvre à des droits et devoirs pour
les états membres et pour le ms et
effectivement cela convocation faite par
le directeur général j'ai reçu l'appel
le dimanche 19 janvier si je me souviens
bien
on peut dire que c'est une convocation
précoce si on compare à ce qui s'était
passé pour ebola et pour h1n1 puis dans
d'autres domaines zika etc
donc je pense que l' oms a fait preuve
de célérité célérité au point que la
première réunion du comité d'urgence le
22 janvier 23 janvier a abouti à un avis
très partagés du comité sur le fait que
c est ce que c'était ou non le comité
était complètement partager tout
simplement parce qu'il y avait quatre
cas à l'étranger de au japon en corée en
thaïlande et que la situation dise on
n'était peut-être pas aussi alarmant 22
22 et 23 janvier
et donc est donc la recommandation qui
alors été faite au directeur ça a été de
lui dire écoute et parce que les termes
de référence de ce comité sont qui doit
fonctionner par consensus et le seul
consensus que j'ai pensé pouvoir trouver
à ce moment là c'était un consensus sur
c'est un peu trop tôt mais reconvoquer
nous dans les jours qui viennent si la
situation évolue ce qu'il a fait la
semaine plus tard nous avons été
convoquée le 30
hélas la situation avait un peu évolué
on était passé de 440 china je crois 17
cents ou même quelques milliers il y
avait non plus quatre cas mais 80 dans
des pays étrangers sans décès dans 18
pays et là le comité a été quasi
unanimes pour dire qu' il fallait
effectivement déclarée et donc le 30
janvier la déclaration par l'om est ce
qu'un événement est une urgence de santé
publique de portée internationale
ça veut dire que dans un pays
normalement on s'arrête de poser le
crayon pose tout et on s'occupe
essentiellement de ça donc la question
effectivement qui peut se poser c'est
qu'est ce qui a été pris comme décision
à partir du 30 janvier au soir et moi
j'avoue que j'ai pas une vision précise
parce que je n'étais pas dans le secteur
des activités au niveau national donc il
est important d'analyser qu'est ce qui
s'est passé en particulier en février et
en mars
c'est là le point à mon avis clé quels
ont été les décisions prises quelles ont
été les plans active et quels ont été
les structures mises en place c'est ça
qui me paraît absolument absolument
essentiel mais je ne suis pas en
position de pouvoir porter véritablement
un jugement personnel parce que je n'ai
pas suivi les affaires de suffisamment
de suffisamment prêt vous évoquez vous
avez évoqué la question de la
coordination de l'ensemble du système
c'est là le problème du défaut de
préparation c'est que lorsqu'on n'est
pas préparé on est obligés d'improviser
et d'inventer des choses alors parfois
avec génie il ya sans doute des
initiatives intéressantes qui ont été
prises mais parfois on crée des ont créé
des choses qui auraient peut-être pu
éviter parce qu'elles ont finalement
créé plus de difficultés que d'abord je
voulais mentionner les deux points qui
m'avait surpris c'est la création du
conseil scientifique et de cayres ça m'a
étonné mais je me suis dit après tout
voyons et puis ce qui m'a surpris c'est
le fait qu'ils aient pas un centre de
crise un centre de gestion de crise
unique alors que dans une situation
aussi grave le plan le plan pandémie
grippale qui a été qu'ils avaient le
mérite d'exister prévoyait tout de même
très rapidement la mise en
un centre de gestion de crise unique ce
qui a finalement être eût été fait au
début du mois de juin
donc je pense que voilà deux exemples
qui sont des manifestations de mon point
de vue d'un défaut de préparation de des
répétitions de ce type de plan
d'exercice où on travaille ensemble ou
on réunit autour de la même table à
santés l'intérieur les affaires
étrangères etc
ça c'est essentiel ensuite alors vous
évoquez ensuite la question de la
coordination locale
là aussi je ne suis pas en position de
pouvoir donner un avis très documenté là
dessus bon la création des ars je les ai
vécu je me suis pas très bien ça a été
une solution qui a été trouvée pour
essayer d'améliorer par rapport à ce
qu'ils avaient avant l'organisation de
l'état en niveau territorial dans le
domaine de la santé et du secteur médico
social
je pense que je ne suis pas bien placé
pour juger des relations qui ont pu
s'établir entre le préfet et la rs d'une
façon générale
de mon point de vue en france lorsqu'il
ya une crise très grave
c'est très important que le préfet soit
aux manettes pourquoi parce que c'est un
acteur interministériel mais il faut le
savoir le ministère de l'intérieur n'est
parfois pas très désireux de porter la
de prendre le le pilotage dans un
secteur où il se sent toujours un tout
petit peu mal à l'aise qui le secteur de
la santé qui est extrêmement technique
où il ya une part d' expertise qui est
très importante en matière d'analysé de
risques si vous voulez quand y'a une
inondation ou un ou un incendie
on va pas demander un conseil
scientifique que voilà c'est on est dans
la gestion et l expertise en matière de
gestion est souvent assez sommaire mais
donc ceci dit je reste convaincu que
dans un événement de ce type il est très
important très vite de m aux manettes le
mini alors les gens du secteur sanitaire
ça leur plaît pas parce que l'idée que
ce soit le ministère de l'intérieur qui
est aux manettes
ça ne leur plaît pas mais je pense qu'en
termes d'efficacité c'est probablement
préalable préférable pardon comment ça
va fonctionner sur l'épisode h1n1 entre
l'intérieur et la santé à l'époque
épisode h1n1 moi je me suis un très bien
qu'en tant que directeur général de la
santé j'avais poussé pour que ce soit le
nissab l'intérieur savait pas tellement
plus arrosée une bachelot d'ailleurs je
crois me souvenir que ce soit madame
alliot marie qui préside la cic mais il
ça me semblait est d'ailleurs ce n'était
pas moi mon avis qu'avec avec conduit à
la décision c'était une décision qui
était prise au niveau gouvernemental
mais ça me paraissait une meilleure
solution plus efficace
merci nous allons passer au groupe avec
que damien abad pour les républicains
merci beaucoup et même la présidente ce
directeur partage à la fois votre
analyse sur le rôle interministériel du
préfet notamment le lien avec avec les
airs et sur ses seins évolution
importante et est également sur ce
deuxième point qui concerne les cellule
interministérielle je voulais vous poser
trois questions de première plus sur
votre casque est entre guillemets à l'
oms le ms avait déclaré notamment
janvier tester tester tester
est ce que vous considérez que ce
message s'adressait aussi à la france ou
uniquement aux pays qui n'avait
absolument aucune plaque capacités de
test est ce que ça voulait dire qu'il
fallait aller une politique massive de
test ou pas ma deuxième question
concerne plus en tant que membre de la
mission castex que l'avait été sur la
question du déconfinement est ce que
vous pensez qu'il aurait été préférable
ou peut-être dans l'avenir de mettre en
oeuvre un confinement plus j'ai
régionaliser ou ciblées si oui comment
vous voyez les choses et puis enfin un
troisième point qui est la plus ancien
directeur général de la santé qui est
bien sûr la question de l' usage des
masques au sein de la population
dans le cas de la pelote du plan de
prévention et de lutte pandémie grippale
vous dites indiqué jack le port de
masques anti-projections peut être
préconisées dans les espaces publics à
titre de précaution avec le public grand
public est encouragé à en faire
l'acquisition
donc et vous dites en même temps en
avril dernier que la culture de la
stratégie des stocks s'est planté donc
quel est le regard pas que vous avez par
rapport justement à l'usagé du masque
notamment pour le pour le grand public
aujourd'hui et si entre guillemets
deuxième vague il y avait et sur
l'évolution
des doctrines intervenu en 2011 et 2013
en matière de stocks d'équipement
stratégique si vous permettez on va
poser encore deux autres questions ça
vous laisse un petit temps donc patrick
mignola pour le modem
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
professeur deux questions également
d'abord par rapport à l' oms lorsque des
éléments d'information seront apportées
pour que vous puissiez vous prononcer
est ce que ces informations au début de
cette année vous pros viennent
naturellement de chine par le biais
uniquement des états où avez vous
d'autres sources ce qui me semble
important pour les élus qui sont ici
dans le cas de reprise de l'épidémie en
d'autres endroits et en d'autres temps
deuxième question vous avez été
parfaitement limpide sur le fait que
notre pays était prêt au début des
années 2010 affronter une épidémie de ce
type
vous avez en revanche étaient lapidaires
ce que je peux parfaitement comprendre
sur le processus de décision qui a
conduit à changer les doctrines quand et
comment et les parlementaires ont ils
été consulté à l'époque sur cette
évolution des doctrines merci boris
ballot pour les socialistes
merci on le présente merci professeur
pardon d'insister sur une sur la
question de l' oms
on a cru comprendre que le comité
d'urgence avait eu quelques divergences
dans l'appréciation de la crise
à ses débuts et avait pu se voir
reprocher une réponse tardive et
notamment le fait de lancer l'urgence
sanitaire de portée internationale a pu
dans certains me critique est jugée
tardive
il a également était dit que l' oms
avait été très influencé par ce que la
chine avait pu lui transmettre ou ne pas
lui transmettre comme information et on
a dans nos auditions à plusieurs
reprises
entendu dire que la chine n'avait pas
été tout à fait transparente je voudrais
savoir quelle est votre appréciation du
point de vue du point de vue des
reproches qui sont faits à l'om ça c'est
la première chose deuxième chose avait
évoqué la question de
l'interministérialité je vais dire au
plan au plan local
vous avez été déléguée
interministérielle au h1n1 ne trompe pas
ce que vous pouvez nous dire en quoi
consistait cette interministériel t
comme des ges et si il vous apparaît que
il y a eu un défaut
d'interministérialité dans la gestion de
la crise actuelle et j'aimerais savoir
de votre point de vue qui a géré la
crise actuelle et puis ben écoutez je
resterai ces deux à ces deux questions
la parole merci madame la présidente je
vais si vous êtes d'accord faire un lot
oms
donc premièrement pour répondre à
monsieur le député abba de tester tester
tester je je je suis pas sûr que c était
une initiative extrêmement heureuse de
donner les choses comme ça parce que
d'abord testé tests et essais ça veut
pas dire grand chose comme vous le savez
ya les tests virologiques ya les tests
sérologiques les capacités des états
sont excessivement différentes et la
notion j'ai été surpris de la
déclaration de l'om est est été testée
parce que d'évidence il ya dans beaucoup
de pays c'était impossible et pas de
test et et même en france l'expérience a
montré que finalement on n'a pu que peut
tester
du moins au début donc je pense que ça a
été une déclaration un tout petit peu
peut-être un petit peu excessive et
alors est ce qu'elle a été sorti du
contexte je ne sais pas c'est possible
mais personnellement ça m'a un tout
petit peu ça m'a un tout petit peu
étonné concernant la concernant la la
question que vous évoquez monsieur
mignola de l'information qui est
apportée dans le cadre de l' oms alors
il faut savoir comment fonctionne ce
comité d'urgence donc la réunion se
tenait à genève il ya toute l'équipe du
directeur général est lui même et au
téléphone il ya d'une part les autorités
sanitaires des pays invités à présenter
la situation dans leur pays en
l'occurrence il y avait eu 6 10e chinese
6 10 6 il y avait les japonais l'état
les thaïlandais les coréens et ces
quatre pays
faisait au départ une présentation de la
situation épidémiologique qui était une
présentation qu'on peut le faire santé
publique france voilà il ya tant de cas
où ça les trucs la mortalité les délais
la transmission le r0 etc etc
ensuite il y avait les quinze experts
enfin les 14 qui était au téléphone en
nouvelle zélande et aux états unis et
ces gens sont invités à bien sûr à poser
des questions et ensuite à prendre
position sur sur la réponse à la
question qui est posée par le directeur
général moi ce que je peux dire c'est
que des informations qui ont été
fournies par les autorités chinoises
le 22 janvier j'avais pas de raison de
douter de la véracité de ses
informations les les chinois avait
annoncé le 31 décembre qu'il y avait des
cas bizarre haouran de pneumopathie
aiguë de cause x peu après ils ont dit
on a trouvé un corps en un virus qui
était pas une bonne nouvelle mais pas
non plus un scoop total ensuite ils ont
séquencé très vite le virus qui montrent
qu'ils ont fait des progrès importants
en matière de génétique moléculaire des
virologiques et ils ont tout de suite
mis cette séquence sur la base
européenne guy cei qui est une base de
données des séquences génétiques des
virus en particulier influenza ce qui
fait qu'on peut pas dire qu'il ait pas
eu de transparence et de volonté de
partager l'information du moins tel que
je l' ai perçu de la part de la part des
chinois et la présentation qui a été
faite alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un
événement bizarre que je peux vous
raconter si ça vous intéresse le 22 au
soir alors qu'on se dirigeait avec le
directeur général pour le point presse
on a appris par une dépêche médias que
la ville d'omran étaient confinés dans
l'après-midi et donc en accord avec le
directeur général il a pris la décision
de faire le directeur général a pris la
décision de dire je demande au comité de
se réunir une journée de plus
parce qu'il faut qu'on comprenne qu est
ce qui s'est passé et pourquoi il ya eu
cette décision est ce que c'est parce
que tous les gens sont décédées dans les
rues de moura nous quel arrêt qu'a été
la raison de cette décision soudaine et
le 23 donc on a eu à nouveau une séance
identique avec les autorités chinoises
le chinese 6 d'ici nous a dit qu'il
avait appris la veille au soir
l'auto confinement de la ville de roanne
qui avait été décidé soit disant par la
ville pour protéger la population
chinoise du hubei du rayman par dont la
chine et le monde entier et donc on a eu
à nouveau des informations sur la
situation épidémiologique qui n'avait
pas vraiment varié et le conseil
le comité d'urgence a été strictement
dans la même attitude
c'est à dire très partagés le seul
consensus que j'ai pu trouver a été
c'est un tout petit peu trop tôt pour
déclarer une urgence de santé publique
de portée internationale
voilà comment les choses se sont passées
alors ensuite j'ai vu dans la presse
effectivement la question de l'
influence sur le directeur général bon
moi ce que je peux vous dire simplement
c'est que monsieur sit-in pin ne m'a pas
appelé et ça je peux vous le garantir g
voilà je n'ai pas eu d'appel ni de sms
sur mon téléphone
alors ensuite il ya une question qui a
été posée également à propos de 2ms par
monsieur le député va l'eau sur le
caractère tardif finalement de la vie
qui a été rendue je me suis posé la
question je me suis dit est-ce que j'ai
pas manquer de nerf est ce que j'aurais
pas dû forcer le groupe à dire etc
c'est vrai qu'on a peut-être perdu une
semaine une semaine ou en même temps je
me souviens d'une époque où on avait dit
à madame chan la déclaration de
l'urgence h1n1 ça a été trop rapide etc
c'est pas facile d'être contre la
précipitation et l'attentisme
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
d'ailleurs demandé au directeur général
qu'un certain nombre de recommandations
soient malgré tout suivi dès le 23
janvier et elle figure dans le state
même que vous pouvez consulter inquiet
public et d'autre part on lui a dit une
chose aussi
n'hésitez pas et même on vous le
recommande à nous reconvoquer si
nécessaire après demain dans les trois
jours dans l'est
dans la semaine ce qui l'a fait
immédiatement donc ce qui l'a fait le 30
le 30 janvier donc voilà je pense que
j'ai réglé le compte de l' oms et j'en
viens maintenant à la question de deux
que vous avez posé monsieur le député
abad sûr est ce que le confinement
aurait pu être plus régionalisés bon
c'est une question difficile parce que
c'est un mécanisme quand même compliqué
qui suppose de prendre des textes qui
suivent cesser tout ça se faisant dans
un climat d'urgence
je sais qu'au sein de l'académie de
médecine
on avait prôné une forme de confinement
à la carte et sur une base régionale
mais je conçois tout à fait que ces pu
apparaître difficile à mettre en oeuvre
dans la réalité
d'abord parce que ça n'est que plus
tardivement qu'on a pu avoir à paraître
s'écarte un peu visualiser qui montrait
un peu la situation épidémiologique
vraiment de façon plus fine par région
par département voilà donc peut-être
mais je pense que c'était quand même
très difficile à mettre en oeuvre
je pense que c'est raide et c'était très
difficile à mettre en oeuvre
on a pu si vous voulez au moment de la
sortie du confinement avoir une approche
différenciée telles que celles que vous
mentionnez mais on a eu quand même un
mois pour se préparer
on a eu un mois pour discuter pour voir
comment allaient s'organiser les
relations entre les régions
enfin c'est on a eu plus de temps pour
préparer la sortie du confinement que
les autorités gouvernementales n'ont eu
pour décider le confinement donc moi je
conçois qu'il était difficile au moment
de la décision du confinement de prendre
une décision fondée sur une base
régionale ou a fortiori départementale
ensuite vous avez posé une question sur
l' usage les usages des masques je ne
sais pas vous étiez peut-être g au début
de mon exposé j'ai dit quelque chose que
choses sur ce sujet donc je voudrais pas
me répéter mais en gros là
la décision qui a été à fond dès
l'acquisition des masques en 2005 2006
2007 et caetera et décisions des
gouvernements d'alors ça a été le
raisonnement suivant face au h5n1
puisqu'il s'agissait à ce moment-là du
virus h5n1 forte mortalité 1 et risque
pandémique
nous n'avons pas à ce moment-là
d'antiviraux nous n'avons pas de vaccin
il faut qu'on puisse se protéger les
professionnels si on veut qu'ils
puissent continuer à travailler et
qu'ils acceptent de continuer à
travailler et donc on a décidé de faire
cette acquisition de masques en grande
partie ffp2 pour les professionnels et
masques chirurgicaux anti projections
j'ai fait de la chirurgie le masque
chirurgical anti-projections c'est pour
éviter de cracher dans le jeu opératoire
ces années ça n'est rien d'autre donc
masques anti projections pour la
population et les malades
alors ensuite il ya une question qui m'a
été posée par monsieur me diola vous
m'avez trouvé lapidaire sur le sujet de
deux des décisions qui ont pu conduire à
l'évaporation des stocks
c'est ça que je comprends dans votre
question alors là on rentre dans la
spéculation
même si votre enquête va permettre
probablement de clarifier les choses
si on fait la petite liste des des
éléments qui peuvent à refonder cette
évaporation
j'en vois plusieurs facteurs le premier
c'est je pense que le fait d'avoir
attaqué aussi fortement ce qui a qui
avaient préparé avec des dépenses une
préparation à un risque pandémique et
qui ont été critiqués parce que
finalement les conséquences sanitaires
n'étaient pas si grave que cela
je pense que ça a marqué les esprits
dans la commission d' enquête précédente
je me souviens que j'avais en face de
moi madame touraine par exemple qui m'a
posé des questions difficiles
est-ce qu'elle était en position de
poursuivre une préparation très active
alors que peu après elle était devenu
ministre de la santé c'est une question
que je me suis posée pour la deuxième la
deuxième question c'est
pardon la deuxième question c'est là la
question de la croyance à l'utilité du
port du masque c'est un point
extrêmement important
là on rentre dans une science qui est un
peu grise parce que effectivement on a
pas d étude contrôlée randomisée qui dit
de manière très démonstrative que dans
telle et telle situation et c'est donc
c'est vrai qu'on est un peu dans le
principe de précaution dans une
incertitude scientifique et
l'acquisition des masses pour protéger
les professionnels et la population
relevé un peu je reconnais du de l'ale
l'application du principe du principe de
du principe de précaution et donc on
peut concevoir que certains finalement
de même qu'ils avaient été un peu choqué
par l'idée on en avait fait trop bas du
coup il devenait finalement un peu
réticent à l'idée de l'intérêt du masque
ça c'est un deuxième facteur qui a pu
intervenir
alors il ya un troisième facteur qui a
sans doute qui est sans doute intervenu
tout bêtement c'est le facteur
budgétaire sire que c'était bilan si
vous êtes un peu hésitant et quand vous
dis bah il vaudrait mieux mettre
l'argent là dessus vous mettre l'argent
là dessus bah vous dites ah bon bah oui
rabat on va en commander que que 20
millions ou 50 millions au lieu d'en
commander 600 millions ça c'est sûr
quatrièmement il faut pas le nier non
plus il ya la question des ddd autre
urgence
il est sûr que en matière de santé on
est en permanence confrontés à des
difficultés qui suppose de mobiliser des
moyens voilà chikungunya à la réunion
faut aller apporter des fonds de
développer la lutte anti vectorielle la
méningite en seine-maritime faut acheter
des vaccins aux norvégiens se parlent
pour la période que j'ai connus mais mes
successeurs ont dû être confrontés à des
difficultés analogues donc effectivement
maintenir le le fil d'une préparation
avec les dépenses que ça impose à mon
avis il faut aller voir du côté des
militaires pour voir comment on fait ce
genre de comment on fait ce genre de
travail donc je ne sais pas si ça répond
pleinement à votre interrogation mais en
tout cas voici un peu comment je vois
les choses
alors je reviens pour terminer à la
question posée par monsieur
ballot de l'interministérialité alors ça
c'est un point extrêmement important
d'abord je précise que j'ai été délégué
interministériel à la lutte contre la
grippe aviaire la grippe aviaire c'est
h5n1 c'est 2005
les choses se sont passées de la manière
suivante en juin 2005
je venais de prendre les fonctions de
directeur général de la santé le sgdn
avait organisé et il avait raison un
grand exercice préparation à une
pandémie grippale et je me suis avec le
ministre bertrand qui venait d'arriver
aussi on a vécu cette cette réunion et
on s'est rendu compte que les a faits a
été sérieuse moi j'ai j'ai dit à ce
moment-là qu'il était très important de
se préparer très activement et j'ai reçu
fin août un appel du ministre me disant
vous êtes désigné délégué
interministériel à la lutte contre la
grippe aviaire s'est expliqué dans ce
bouquin si ça vous intéresse
j'ai organisé à partir de ce jour là
tous les mardis matin une réunion mardi
grippe et une réunion infogrippe ont
passé en revue tout ce qu'il était
nécessaire de préparer j'avais une
petite équipe avec un intérieur 1 m à 1
minefi 2 igas un travail et puis on
réunissait tous les ministères concernés
et ont passé les secteurs tous les
secteurs en revue pour cette préparation
et on faisait la même chose en terme de
communication à travers cette réunion
infogrippe et je pense qu'on a réussi à
créer une dynamique de préparation qui a
fait que petit à petit ceux qui s'en
souviennent qu'ils ont été aux affaires
à ce moment là se souviennent que là on
essayait de préparer les collectivités
locales les entreprises etc pour se
préparer à ça ce risque alors c'est vrai
qu'en 2008
et c'était vrai dans d'autres pays est
apparu un peu de fatigue pandémique les
gens se sont dit bon bon bon d'accord on
se prépare on se prépare ans préfère
mais finalement ce virus ne n'arrive pas
et la question de comment se préparer
dans la durée un risque pandémique est
très important d difficile et je pense
qu'il vaudrait mieux voir les choses de
façon plus générique et c'est pour la
raison pour laquelle je propose la
préparation au risque pandémique en
général plutôt que de cibler sur un
agent infectieux parce que malgré tout
l'inventivité de
microbiologie et tels que il va nous
sortir quelque chose de différent dans
quelques mois ou quelques années
alors vous avez posé une dernière
question c'est qui a géré la crise
ben je je je pense que vous parlez de la
crise la crise actuelle bon moi j'ai dit
ce que je pensais de de la mise en place
de trois cellules un terme istres 3
cellules de crise l'une à l'intérieur
l'autre à la santé l'autre au mae
bon ça m'a je pensais que c'était mieux
de rassembler tout le monde
mais d'évidence c'est le premier
ministre et c'est son équipe qui ont
assuré le pilotage de le pilotage de la
crise 1 ça se joue à un niveau politique
élevé ce genre d'affaires merci alors
jean christophe lagarde pour lui dire
merci
le président d'abord je tiens à dire au
professeur ou cinq dans le travail qui a
été fait en 2010 les journalistes ont
interprété qu'il y en avait eu trop de
fait la réalité c'est que c'était mal
fait et sans doute mal préparé par le
secrétaire général la défense nationale
je le dis parce que j'ai eu beaucoup de
polémiques là dessus une opinion
personnelle
deuxième chose vous avez dit quelque
chose d'essentiel il sait passer du
temps entre le 30 janvier alerte
mondiale oms et le temps où en réalité
on parvient à réagir et jeudi pour
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur il me semble que la
commission denquête dans quelques jours
aura à s'orienter sur cette latence là
je reviens à vous nos abonnés nous a
expliqué que la date de péremption des
masques chirurgicaux qui nous ont tant
manqué et finalement quelque chose de
récent ça date de 2010 et donc 2010 ça
veut dire que vous étiez en fonction
est-ce que c'était une demande
récurrente des fabricants est ce que
c'est une décision qui a été par dont
l'une est de l'anglicisme challenge et
par le ministère de la santé c'est à
dire qu'après tout on sait bien que ces
masses continue à conserver le capacité
protectrice protectrice plus longtemps
que la date de péremption qui a été mise
en clair est ce que on a essayé de faire
en sorte de déterminer si oui ou non il
était efficace plus longtemps et puis
est-ce que à l'époque
on pensait déjà à une éventuelle
défaillance d'un producteur marché
chinois ce qui nous est arrivé
et est ce qu'on avait imaginé quelque
chose pour le remplacer la deuxième
chose c'est que vous êtes le père de
l'eprus lors de la commission denquête
que vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure avec
notre collègue jean pierre door nous
avions émis l'idée qu' il fallait
adapter l'organisation des stocks de
masques et d'équipements de protection
aux zones de défense puisque ce sont les
préfets les autres de défense qui était
censé à la fois les surveiller et le cas
échéant les déployer pourquoi est ce que
cette recommandation qui nous semblaient
de bon sens n'a pas été mise en oeuvre à
votre connaissance puisque ça s'est fait
un peu après et enfin vous l'évoquez des
exercices de catastrophes que vous
organisiez régulièrement
alors pardon les mardis grippe mais il
ya eu aussi les exercices catastrophe
qui était organisée me semble-t-il
lorsque vous étiez là est ce que votre
connaissance ça lui a été profitable
et deuxième chose surtout est-ce que ça
a continué après comme vous disiez il ya
une certaine fatigue delà du risque
pandémique
est-ce qu'ils ont continué ensuite à
organiser ce type d'exercice pour qu'on
soit réellement prêt merci monsieur
points chers oui je voulais compléter la
question que jean christophe lagarde
benoît valais qui a exercé vos fonctions
de 2013 à 2014 évoque des changements
norme chez les producteurs de masques
avec des dates de péremption ce qui
conduit pour l'état en 2014 à
généraliser ces normes y compris pour
les stocks anciens et entraîner un audit
sur la totalité de nos stocks la
destruction de 80% d'entre eux à partir
de 2018 est d'ailleurs françois
bourdillon le 17 juin dernier l'ancien
directeur de santé publique france il
arrive il fait ce constat
il ya 600 millions de masques qui sont
plus opérationnels ils envoient dire un
courrier directeur général de la santé
pour alerter
on ne commande que 100 millions de
masques en deux parties donc on arrive
complètement désarmé à l'entrée de la
crise mais je reviens je reviens en 2010
en 2010 on constate donc il ya des
normes avec des dates de péremption
devait donc se doutait qu'il fallait
effectuer une analyse la totalité de nos
stocks
ce que les producteurs eux-mêmes
considéré qu'il n'était plus fiable à
100% que dans un délai d'ailleurs limité
pourquoi avoir à votre avis autant
attendu pour partir de ce constat voir
analyser l'ensemble des masques et puis
les avoir chez les avoir changées je
sais que vous n'avez quitter vos
fonctions qu'en 2011 et peut-être
pourriez-vous nous éclairer sur ce sujet
et enfin quel jugement vous portez sur
l'absence d' achat de nouveaux masques
en 2018 en nombre suffisant ainsi que
sur la destruction d'un important stock
qui aurait pu être utilisé dans d'autres
cadres
merci caroline fiat
vous vouliez poser une question c'est
pas une obligation
alors and is you noter la république en
bas merci madame la présidente monsieur
d'acteurs merci beaucoup pour pour vous
exposer qu'ils sont très claires et très
cash et j'apprécie beaucoup vous avez
dit tout à l'heure dans le cadre de vos
fonctions vous aviez notamment dans
votre cadre de fonctions comme délégué
interministériel à la lutte contre la
grippe aviaire précisé que moi même je
travaillais en 2006 7 8 en asie sur les
plans de préparation de continuité
d'activité des entreprises en asie
notamment sur la région de hong kong est
du japon et de la corée donc un sujet
que je connais assez bien
vous expliquez que vous avez de vie
rencontrer tous les secteurs pour les
inciter à deux choses préparées à leur
plan de continuité d'activité et acheter
des masques donc j'entends à travers
cela que vous avez vraiment une lecture
de ce qu'il convient de faire entre
votre expérience en fonction à l'époque
ce que vous avez suivi de ce qui vient
de se passer est ma question concerne la
suite actuellement nous parlons et
comment vous voyez l'organisation
aujourd'hui qu'elle et quels sont vos
conseils d'organisation que ce soit
au niveau des entreprises au niveau des
institutions au niveau des du secteur de
la santé que comment devrions-nous
aujourd'hui nous organiser pour pouvoir
être prêt que signifie être prêt vous
avez juste esquissé le fait qu'il vaut
mieux être prêt pour une pandémie au
sens général mais je rappelle qu'une
pandémie
il peut être une transmission
respiratoires manuel sanguine il ya
beaucoup de façons de se préparer donc
la plage soit ma préparation est très
vaste
quel est votre regard comment faut-il se
préparer on entend parler régulièrement
je pense que le prochain
auditionné va nous parler de cette
fameuse deuxième vague
que faut-il faire aujourd'hui pour être
prêt on n'entend pas beaucoup parler
quel est votre regard sur le niveau de
préparation que nous devrions avoir je
vous remercie
merci et martin vos nerfs pour le groupe
edf merci madame la présidente monsieur
jeu revient quelques instants sur la
problématique des masques
vous êtes en fonction en 2010 vous
quittez votre fonction 2011 et en 2010
s'il me semble vous allez nous le
préciser que vous êtes le signataire
d'une circulaire très clair qui parlait
de la stratégie de retrait logistique
des stocks de masques ffp2 est ce exact
est ce que vous avez pu évaluer avant
votre départ en 2011 l'impact de cette
circulaire parce qu'au fond n'est-ce pas
vous qui avez j'allais dire enclenché
peut-être cette nouvelle stratégie sur
les masques et au fond comme vous le
dites si bien c'est aujourd'hui ce
constat que la france n'était absolument
pas prête et absolument pas protégés
deuxième question et j'en arrêterait la
sur la gouvernance vous est plusieurs
fois revenu mais au fond est-ce qu'on
n'était pas là dans la caricature de sur
tout ce qu'il ne fallait pas faire parce
qu'entre les différentes cellules de
crise les nombreuses agences qui
fonctionne de façon indépendante et
individuelles
le conseil stratégique est-ce que la
stratégie utilisée pendant cette crise
qu vide n'était page tout ce qu'il ne
fallait pas faire
je vous remercie merci merci madame la
présidente alors je vais passer en revue
au fur et à mesure peut-être les les
questions en espérant ne pas ne pas ne
pas oublier des points
alors d'abord pour monsieur monsieur le
député lagarde
et ça vaudra aussi pour l'art et la
question que vous venez de poser madame
concernant les masques bon il y avait à
ce moment là deux types de masse il y
avait le masque chirurgical qui est un
dispositif médical qui est un produit
qui à cette époque là n'avaient pas de
date de péremption pour une raison très
simple c'est que c'est des produits qui
n'étaient pas destinées à des produits
stockés c'était des produits d'usagé
courant en chirurgie en sti et pour les
infirmiers etc etc
donc les le milliard de masques
chirurgicaux
je me souviens avoir été visitées langat
où ils étaient stockés dans les années
2007-2008 dans l'art en seine et marne
c'était des masques je dirais qu'il a
annoncé qu'il démarche qui n'avaient pas
de date de péremption est donc la
question du renouvellement du stock
à cette époque là ne se posait pas
véritablement autre sujet les masques
ffp2 les masques ffp2 c'est une affaire
complètement différente parce que les
masques ffp2 ce ne sont pas des
dispositifs médicaux
c'est ce qu'on appelle des équipements
de protection individuelle qui relèvent
de la réglementation du travail et qui
sont des masses qui ont sont censés
avoir une capacité de filtration vers le
porteur dès lors qu'ils sont bien
portées et cette capacité de filtration
et l'ailier a des propriétés et les
hydro etc trop statique du tissu et
c'est bon je rentre pas dans les détails
techniques que d'hayange est un petit
peu oublié mais ce qui est très
important c'est que lorsque nous avions
un site et en france à la création d'une
industrie de fabrication de ces masques
je me suis un trait mais j'avais été
visité l'usiné de macopharma
nord à mouvaux et puis il y avait les
usines de toine paul boyer il y avait
bacou-dalloz en bretagne on avait lancé
des marchés qui avait permis à ses
industries de montée des chaînes et de
produire ces masques ffp2 et une des
discussions qu'on avait eue avec les
industriels je me souviens très bien
c'avait été qu'au départ il avait dit
notre délai de péremption ces trois ans
alors avait dit écoutez trois ans et ça
comme on veut quand même en acheter
beaucoup ça va quand même posé des
problèmes
donc est-ce que vous ne pourriez pas
réexaminé vos masques et je crois me
souvenir qu'il y avait des études qui
avaient été faites
ali nrs qui était à ce moment là le qui
est l organisme dépendant du ministère
du travail qui avait fait des tests de
filtration et en gros en accord avec les
industriels
là le délai de péremption de ces masques
avait été porté à 5 ans est donc
évidemment il était sûr que ayant
commencé à acquérir des masques en 2005
il y avait un certain nombre de masse
qui en 2010 arrivés à péremption et pour
lequel il était non seulement je dirais
logique mais souhaitable
dès lors qu'ils avaient perdu leur quête
capacité de filtration n'allait pas
donner à des professionnels de santé des
masses qui avaient perdu leur capacité
de filtration alors que justement on
voulait leur offrir quelque chose qui
leur permettrait d'être protégé donc
effectivement il est très possible je me
souviens pas de cette circulaire mais il
est très possible qu'on est enclenché un
mécanisme de je dirais de de
remplacement des masques les plus et
plus anciens mais ça ne voulait pas dire
que j'avais en tête l'idée qu'il fallait
supprimer le stock de masques de masques
ffp2 ça c'est ça c'est la première
première question sur sur les sur les
les masques alors monsieur le député
lagarde vous m'avez posé aussi une
question à propos de l'eprus et à propos
de alors j'avoue que je ne me souviens
pas si pourquoi ces masses moi j'avais
gardé le souvenir que ces masques avait
été posée en groupe positionné en grande
partie alors est ce que c'était avant ou
après la création de l'épreuve je ne me
souviens pas mais dans les zones de
défense et on avait une organisation qui
avait essayé de suivre justement le
principe des deux principes des zones de
défense
quant aux exercices ça vous mettez le
doigt sur un point extrêmement important
c'est qu'effectivement
je ne sais pas si à partir de 2011 et
dans les années suivantes il ya eu des
actes exercice du type de ceux que
organiser le sgdn exercice biotox
exercice pirates ox exercice pandémie là
il y avait d'ailleurs des formes
d'exercice jaune souhait d'une haine
d'une période où on avait fait plusieurs
dizaine d'exercices dans toute la france
dans des petites villes dans des grandes
villes
je me suis un des dunes d'un exercice
avec la préfète de la région
ile-de-france donc effectivement c'est
très important de maintenir de maintenir
alerte le dispositif de préparation et
l'exercice est une chose essentielle
c'est pas à confondre avec le retour
d'expérience et autres choses autour
d'expériences il s'est passé un
événement on tire les leçons l'exercice
et on sent on se prépare dans la durée
c'est une chose tout à fait tout à fait
différente
alors ensuite je vais répondre peut-être
à monsieur je suis pas sûr d'avoir bien
se pencher un pêcheur pencher à
pardonnez-moi penchèrent oui donc je
reviens pas sur la question de des
normes et de la péremption parce que
effectivement moi j'ai perdu le fil à
partir de 2011 sur l'évolution de la
réglementation concernant les masques et
j'avoue je ne voudrais pas vous dire de
bêtises
si benoît valait vous a donné ses
informations il n'y a pas de raison de
deux y'a pas de raison de douter
bon en revanche c'est sûr que messager
évoqué tout à l'heure la question
pourquoi si on détruit des masques parce
qu'ils sont vraiment périmés vraiment
abîmé qu'on a effectivement eu la
conviction qu'ils ne pourraient être
utilisés par personne faisons le mais il
faut quand même bien réfléchir avant de
détruire des quantités très importantes
de ma surtout de masques chirurgicaux
qui a priori sont pas des masques dont
la péremption est quand même évidente
la deuxième chose c'est la question des
achats ben je vais pas revenir dessus
parce que je crois que j'ai déjà dit que
effectivement s'il n'y a pas un budget
sanctuarisée dans le cadre d'un plan de
préparation avec un contrôle de 10 ont
suivi des stocks et de leur maintien
effectivement et ça risque de passer ça
risque de passer à la trappe
alors madame gendt et vous vous avez
évoqué ça me fait plaisir que les pca
et atteint y compris l'extrême orient
vous avez évoqué la question de
l'organisation du conseil
bon moi je me souviens quand on disait
quand on me posait la question en 2007
2008 est ce que vous êtes prêt je disais
non nous ne sommes pas prêts nous nous
préparons ces deux choses différentes
comment comment pouvoir prétendre être
prêt à un événement dont on ne connaît
pas les caractéristiques et qui
évidemment aura des éléments de surprise
en revanche s'inscrit dans une dynamique
de préparation c'est à dire avoir un
plan s'exercer évaluer ce plan je
rappelle que le plan pandémie grippale
on l'avait fait évaluer par des
autorités européennes je crois que c'est
la langue donne school of tropical
medicine
aydin qui avait évalué notre plan
pandémie grippale parce qu'on voulait
être sûr d'avoir un regard extérieur sur
la qualité de ceux de ce plan donc alors
si vous voulez donner des conseils c'est
un peu c'est un peu difficile
et j'aurais tendance malheureusement à
retomber dans ce que j'ai connu et 2
alors que peut-être il faut faire preuve
d'innovation
donc ce dont je suis sûr c'est que il
faut une volonté politique très forte
si on a pu se préparer en 2005 2006 2007
c'est pour une raison très simple c'est
que au décours de l'exercice pandémie
grippale du sgdn chirac a dit en
septembre dépenses pour la préparation à
une pandémie grippale nos limites ça je
me suis un très bien et ça a créé un
boost moi j'ai fait que accompagné à une
décision politique au plus haut niveau
donc si vous voulez s'il n'y a pas une
ça dans bright pas donc ça c'est la
première chose décision politique au
plus haut niveau conviction que c'est
très important
deuxièmement organisation adaptée avec
alors le sgdn c'est des gens qui savent
faire des plans mais il faut
effectivement aussi d un coordonnateur
interministériel qui va faire travailler
un peu ce qu'a fait jean castex dans le
cadre de sa mission sortie confirmant
moi j'ai retrouvé ce que j'avais vécu
alors évidemment lui l'a fait à une
échelle plus importante mais ce que
j'avais vécu dans le cadre de la
préparation à une pandémie une pandémie
grippale et puis ensuite il ya la
question des est ce que j'ai dit à la
faim et à la question des moyens d
des produits à la question des exercices
ya la question de l'évaluation de ce qui
ce fait il ya la comparaison avec les
pays européens
il ya la recherche et le développement
parce que finalement c'est comme un peu
misérable de se retrouver sans me sens
médicaments sans vaccin sans rien alors
que je dis pas que c'est facile de créer
mais peut-être qu'on aurait pu savoir
qu'on avait eu un merde coronavirus on a
eu le sera souvent nés la recherche sur
les vaccins quand coco en aviez
peut-être qu'on n'en trouvera pas
peut-être qu'on va se retrouver comme
pour archiver avec finalement un bon
médicament est pas de vaccin ça je n'en
sais rien enfin pour terminer vous avez
évoqué la question de la gouvernance
madame bonheur ce beau meert monnaire
pardonnez moi vous avez évoqué la
gouvernance le nombre d'agents selon 2cv
crise j'ai dit pendant l'exposé que
effectivement il ya deux choses qui
m'avait paru bizarre c'était la création
du conseil scientifique et de cayres
mais bon je me suis dit peut-être c'est
un coup de génie
et puis ensuite il ya eu la question de
la multiplicité des cellules de crise
voilà ce qui était peut-être un peu
dommage c'est qu'on se soit pas appuyer
beaucoup plus délibérément sur des
structures qui existent qui ont fait
leurs preuves qui sont à mon avis santé
publique france et le haut conseil de
santé publique qui dondon en plus la
composition et sécurisée avec les
déclarations d'intérêts avec etc
et puis c'est des gens qui ont
l'habitude de travailler en matière de
d'expertisé voilà donc mais bon parfois
l'innovation peut avoir du bon
merci nous avons encore pas mal de
questions jean pierre door tout d'abord
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
houssin on a traversé quelques années
ensemble et vous avez vous avez dit
beaucoup de choses que je retrouve dans
le plan pandémie que on l'avait analysé
avec mon collègue jean marie le guen à
l'époque et dont j'étais le rapporteur
et qui montrent effectivement les 250
fiches actions qui décrivent qui
découlait de ce plan pandémie et je
voudrais citer simplement une des
phrases que vous aviez dit à propos des
masques parce que pour nous le problème
des masques est un problème extrêmement
important surtout quand on voit le ce
bal qui s'est créée entre est-ce que
c'est utile pas utile de me souviens de
votre phrase était celle ci des travaux
scientifiques qui montrent que le port
de masques à hong kong durant l'épidémie
du strass a entraîné une diminution
significative du nombre d'affections
respiratoires alors même qu'il
s'agissait de simple masque en tissu
beaucoup plus rigoureux dimon terre que
les masques ffp2 c'est à dire que le
masque était devenue une nécessité et
dans nos plans nous avions parlé d'
obligations de masques en cas de
pandémie
bon ce qui fait que vous avez dit dans
une dans un journal je ne sais plus
lequel grave que vous étiez très fier de
la création de l'eprus pensez bien aussi
moi aussi surtout que j'aimerais bien
que l'on pût oui je le dis parce que
j'étais le rapporteur de la loi sur le
russe est gelée vu construire à marolles
où ils là où ils ont retrouvé là-bas
tous les stocks dont vous avez parlé
j'aimerais savoir aussi le problème des
respirateurs carrier eu un problème au
niveau de questions sur les respirateurs
et nous avions ciblé avec le ministre
6000 respirateur qui devait être
stockées donc je pense que si nous les
avions
nous aurions plus pas 5000 lits de
réanimation dont pouvoir
dix mille dès l'instant où on aurait eu
ces stocks de respirateurs vous avez et
cibler la coordination territoriale
quelque chose de fondamental et quand
vous avez fait nous avons fait les
expériences locales
ça a montré que les territoires étaient
favorables à pouvoir s'engager dans une
réponse aux épidémies
donc je pense que c'est un engagement
qu'il faudra avoir pour demain vous
remercie merci julien brault zik
oui merci à madame la présidente vous
vous l'avez dit tout ça c'est un point
important on avait sur ce coronavirus
qui n'était pas le premier coronavirus
auquel on était confronté mais sur ce
qu'on a vu en quinze jours trois
semaines souvent de retard de diagnostic
parfois parce qu'on avait un risque de
contamination d'excrétion avant
l'apparition des signes et donc on avait
parfois un retard et donc cela prouve
peut être ai je voulais vous interrogez
là dessus sur la difficulté qu'on a et
vous l'avez déjà déjà dit qu'on a à
s'adapter finalement une à une crise
donc at on besoin quand même aussi
parfois pour rebondir ce que vous disiez
de de création de structures qui
permettent plus de souplesse plus
d'adaptation plus d'agilité dans des
crises sur lesquels on ne maîtrise pas
tout et ça fait la transition que ma
deuxième question vous avez vous parliez
justement des agences qui sont en place
et on a vu effectivement d'abord la
création je voulais avoir votre regard
sur le conseil scientifique avait été
mis en place avec la dimension sociale
éthique anthropologique peut-être dont
il y avait peut-être besoin en plus
dense est dans ce cadre là et au delà de
ça le professeur delfraissy nous disait
avec la nécessité aussi de pouvoir
travailler de faire travailler ensemble
c'est la danse qui parfois ne
travaillent pas ensemble et de la même
manière également qu'il y a eu il me
semble et vous me donnerez votre avis
sur son action une cellule de crise
interministérielle pilotée par matignon
qui a
agi pendant deux mois et à laquelle le
rapport castex justement auquel vous
participiez je crois a mis fin au 19 mai
en demandant à ce qu'on passe sur une
autre modalité en sortie de deux de
confinement dernière dernier point
rapidement sur lequel jours et vous vous
interrogez c'est votre regard au moment
où vous êtes en activité
votre regard sur la souveraineté
française par rapport aux masques et la
fabrication de masques je vous pose la
question parce que je je je je je cite
l'ancien président de l' usine de
plaintel rollin le rôle enfants gens qui
nous dit de janvier 2009 à septembre
2010 nous avons livré 160 millions de
masques ffp2 à l'état et puis il ya eu
un désengagement de l'état la chute des
commandes a été catastrophique pour
l'usiné il en prenait la suite merci
merci j'ai encore prendre une question
monsieur gautier merci madame la
présidente
trois professeurs je voudrais revenir
sur vos fonctions de président du comité
d'urgence
coville 19 à l'om est ce même s'il a
déjà été abordé parce que c'est quand
même là que tout a commencé
à partir du moment où la chine et taïwan
ont signalé le 31 décembre 2019 les
premiers cas de pneumopathies jusqu'à
l'annoncé la reconnaissance 30 janvier
2020 de l'épidémie comme urgences de
santé publique à portée internationale
quasiment un mois jour pour jour entre
les deux dates c'est peu et beaucoup à
la fois
alors est-ce que de questions au niveau
national et international au niveau
national avez-vous en dehors de ce
message officiel de l'om s échanger
personnellement avec les autorités
françaises
madame busin le premier ministre de
façon formelle après le 30 janvier ou
peut-être même de façon informelle avant
le 30 janvier
et puis au niveau international alors
j'ai entendu vos réponses par rapport à
d'éventuelles pressions de la chine
votre absence de doute
à l'époque avez vous entendu également
les signalements de taiwan quasiment la
même date
dès le 31 décembre 2019 puisque taïwan a
fermé sa frontière
le 22 janvier avec la chine très très
tôt si explique peut-être aussi son
excellent bilan
donc cette mort pour 23 millions
d'habitants
c'est comme s'il y avait 20 morts en
france vous voyez le delta cette mort
uniquement et 446 cas pour 23 millions
d'habitants
merci sophie auconie oui rapidement pour
compléter vos propos professeur et merci
de la clarté de de ces derniers aussi
vous avez été directeur général de la
santé lors de la grippe aviaire et vous
aviez indiqué à ce moment là que c'était
une menace importante pour l'espèce
humaine en la compara en la comparant
possiblement avec des pandémies comme la
peste ou la grippe espagnole plus d'une
décennie plus tard
lakovic 19 a été considérée en france
comme une simple grippette
comment expliquez-vous en si peu de
temps la différence entre le sérieux
avec lequel avait été appréhendé la
grippe aviaire est ce que je
qualifierais de légèreté d'appréciation
la copie 19 deuxième sujet je crois que
vous êtes à l'origine de la de
l'organisation territoriale de la santé
à travers notamment les uns les ars ck
ou pas et en tout état de cause
j'ai le sentiment personnel que cette
organisation terre-à-terre territoriale
ne représente pas une même égalité de
traitement pour les territoires qu'en
pensez vous est ce qu'on peut corriger
cette organisation pour la rendre plus
efficace plus efficiente notamment dans
la gestion d'une crise comme celle que
nous venons de traverser et que nous
traverserons peut-être encore dans les
mois prochains
enfin pour ce qui concerne la gestion
des stocks et pour rebondir sur les
quelques questions la question de jean
christophe lagarde au niveau de la
gestion des stocks entre les les stocks
chirurgicaux les stocks des masques des
masques chirurgicaux et ceux qui étaient
ffp2 quels sont les points
qui ont été des faiblesses et qu'elle
commentait ce qu'on peut améliorer la
gestion l'organisation de la gestion de
ses stocks qu'ils soient ffp2 ou
chirurgicaux je vous remercie
merci je vais faire passer la parole
sachant que nous aurons encore trois
questions ensuite merci même le
président tout d'abord je suis fier que
vous soyez fier d'avoir créé les plus
parce qu'effectivement je considère que
ça a été un acquis dans notre paysage
je rappelle que c'est à la suite d'une
visite aux états unis à cette époque là
les états unis était un modèle où
effectivement j'avais constaté qu'ils
avaient deux choses que nous n'avions
pas d'une part un corps de santé
publique
le leur était en uniforme j'ai pas été
jusqu'à recommander que le nôtre soit en
uniforme et 1 1 disons une organisation
de gestion des stocks de produits de
santé qui m'a conduit à proposer au
ministre bertrand à l'époque la création
d'un établissement parce que j'avais
fait le constat que la dgs n'était pas
capable n'avait pas les compétences en
matière de logistique pour prendre tout
seul en chasse ce genre de ce genre de
travail dit d'où la création de l'eprus
et merci d'avoir rappelé la sur les
respirateurs effectivement nous avions
été amenés à commander des respirateurs
mais ce sont des produits assez je
dirais fragile qui n'est qu'ils doivent
aussi fonctionner c'est un respirateur
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut poser
sur une étagère on ferme le placard et
on attend pendant dix ans il faut qu'ils
fonctionnent et donc on avait positionné
je me souviens c'est respirateur dans
les établissements de santé
et effectivement on avait fait ça alors
il ya eu surtout une acquisition
importante aussi au moment de la
pandémie grippale h1n1 durant l'été 2009
où effectivement on avait également
complété l'acquisition de deux
respirateurs pour essayer de faire face
alors je ne sais pas si dans cette crise
il ya eu des difficultés sur les
respirateurs c'est possible mais j'avoue
que j'ai pas été au courant de vraiment
de 7,2 cette question en monsieur ben
dit que concernant le le ya un point
très important c'est qu'effectivement il
a été montré par une équipe de recherche
en allemagne que ce ce virus a une
capacité tout à fait préoccupant qui est
d'être deux
d'être excrété par le malade dans les 48
heures qui précède l'apparition des
signes et ça c'est un problème très
important parce que ça veut dire qu'on
peut pas demander à quelqu'un je veux
dire toute personne devient
potentiellement un ex créateurs de virus
et c'est la raison pour laquelle la
question des regroupements en espace
confiné de personnes etc devient un
sujet extrêmement difficile à gérer
parce que vous pouvez toujours dire haut
ce qu'ils sentent malades vont bien
rester chez vous mais ceux qui sentent
pas encore malade et ils vont rentrer et
donc ça c'est une des difficultés
particulières qui a été posée je pense
par le coran navires us vous avez raison
d'avoir souligne aussi qu'un des aspects
positifs je pense du conseil
scientifique ça a été basse a été liée à
la personnalité de delfraissy qui en
tant que président du ccn a une tonalité
et une appétence pour les questions je
dirais éthique qui était utile aussi ils
sont très importantes dans le cas d'une
gestion de ce type dont je pense que ça
a été un des éléments positifs de la
création du du conseil scientifique
ensuite madame j'aurais pas oublier un
intervenant
madame ont connu donc bon vous avez dit
que effectivement on avait pris très au
sérieux la menace h5n1
ce qui je pense qu'il faut aussi voir
que h5n1 on était face à une menace de
pandémie
l'om est ça dit il faut vous préparer et
heureusement les autorités françaises
ont dit on va se préparer et on s'est
préparé mais on a eu du temps pour se
préparer
qu'ovide comme on n'était pas bien
préparé c'est tombé boom et en fait on
est tombés sur des esprits peut-être pas
assez préparés donc ça veut dire que si
on veut résoudre ce genre de difficultés
il faut se préparer en permanence et se
préparer en permanence c'est difficile
c'est difficile parce que ça suppose une
une persistance une ténacité y compris
dans la volonté politique et on sait
qu'elle peut varier y compris dans les
moyens voilà donc c'est une grande
difficulté alors je sais pas comment
font les militaires pour se préparer a
pas eu de grandes guerres depuis disons
de blain mais il arrive quand même à
continuer à se préparer je pense qu'il
faut 5
pire et de ça enfin concernant la alors
l'organisation territoriale inégalités
effectivement j'avais participé
c'est pas moi qui avais consul nefa
j'avais participé à la création du fonds
de la réorganisation territoriale de
l'état avec la disparition des drass das
la création des ars le rôle des ars la
coordination drs pas moi j'avais
toujours considéré que c'était quand
même un progrès effectivement à des
grands sujets c'était comment lutter
contre les inégalités territoriales et
sociales de santé dont comment pouvoir
mettre en place des mécanismes de
compensation toujours difficile entre
entre régions surtout si on songe à
l'outre-mer ou la question est encore
plus encore plus critique
voilà alors bon c'est vrai que dans
cette épidémie dans cette pandémie
qu'ovide 19
on a été confronté à curieusement à une
inégalité territoriale extraordinaire
parce que pourquoi est ce que c'est si
on a des idées mais pourquoi ça s'est
limité au nord-est de la france et le
sud ouest pas grand chose
et finalement où est la justice dans
cette affaire qu'est ce qu'on a c'est
pas facile de gérer une inégalité dans
un contexte comme celui-là je pense
qu'il ya des initiatives heureuses qui
ont été prises notamment de transferts
de patients entre régions vers
l'allemagne de transfert y compris de
patients enfin c'est un petit exploit
qui a été réalisée quand même avec ces
transferts de patients intubé et ventilé
enfin c'est pas des affaires faciles ça
voilà écoutez je vais peut-être vous
avez posé je crois une question sur la
gestion des stocks et faiblesses mais
jugez pas retenu exactement quel était
le sens de votre question oui elle
revenait si vous le permettez vous avez
dit et tout fort justement la date de
péremption elle est parfaitement
compréhensible sur le ffp2 oui sur le
ffp un fabricant 10 2010 simplement il
pose la question pour savoir venir y
répondre mais le président et vous avez
dit c'est vrai que pour les masques
chirurgicaux donc la ffpsc beaucoup plus
discutable à date de péremption c'est
sur ça que je vous interrogeait est-ce
que ça a été challenge et avec les
fabricants à un moment ou un autre à
votre connaissance qui avait pas de date
de péremption des masques chirurgicaux
entre 2005 et 2011
moi j'ai pas connue même de discussions
sur ce sujet il n'y avait pas de date de
péremption des masques chirurgicaux
merci vous avez pardon monsieur excusez
moi voulait c'est ça le danger d de ces
discussions qui ne s'organise pas et
vous aviez terminé votre intervention
monsieur parce que j'ai encore trois
questions alors nicolas des moulins oui
monsieur ou ça vous avez mis l'accent
sur le manque de préparation que
j'entends pleinement vous n'êtes vous
avez parlé des hauts niveaux des masques
n'ai pas parlé de l'utilisation des
masques je pense que vous devez avoir un
recul là dessus en france et en europe
notamment on n'a pas cette norme
culturelle de ce qu'on appelle le bien
porter ou l'avait dit tout à l'heure
qu'est ce que vous préconisez là-dessus
ce que je ne suis pas sûr aujourd'hui
malgré la pandémie qu'en france on est
bien compris le l'utilisation de ce
masque moi je l'aï vu sur le terrain
beaucoup de français porté le masque et
éviter les gestes barrière qui me semble
être quand même à une sécurité un peu
plus importantes dont là je voulais
avoir votre garde là dessus et deuxième
question sur le la réserve sanitaire si
je dis pas de bêtises je crois que c'est
d'ailleurs l'eprus qui ont été à
l'initiative
qu'est-ce qui régresse qui pourrait être
amélioré au niveau de cette réserve
sanitaire durant cette crise même s'il
ya eu de très bonnes choses je pense que
dans les futures crises serait peut-être
bien de l'améliorer de l'intensifier au
niveau de l'organisation
merci merci je sais encore de loups
merci madame la présidente
trois questions synthétique nous avons
fréquemment évoqué la peine que nous
avions à apprendre des épisodes
précédents et vous évoquiez dans le
quotidien du pharmacien le 10 avril
je vous cite nous n'avons pas pu agir
dans le long terme il n'a pas été
possible de gérer les stocks constitués
de ffp2 qui arrivés à péremption en cinq
ans est-ce que sous cette dénomination
il n'a pas été possible
vous évoquez uniquement la ligne
budgétaire consacrée à l'achat des
masques qui n'avaient pas pu être
respectées en raison des arbitrages du
ministère note
man par rapport aux imprévus que vous
aviez citer une autre petite question
concernant la changement le changement
de doctrine en 2013
celle ci a beaucoup été évoqué comme
étant la source de nombreux maux il me
semble cependant qu'elle était plus axé
sur l'aspect qualitatif des masques que
l'aspect quantitatif puisqu'il était
donc évoqué ffp2 serait désormais acquis
par des établissements de santé alors
que les masques chirurgicaux serait
gérée par l'état est d'ailleurs un
rapport d'experts de santé publique
france en 2019 faisait état que nous
avions toujours besoin d'un milliard de
masques qu'ils devaient contrôler que
ces achats de masques ffp2 et bien été
effectuées par les établissements santé
et puis une troisième question très
rapide par rapport à la tension au
regard des médicaments des anesthésiants
mais pas que puisque nous l'avons vu les
patients qu'aux vide pour beaucoup
d'entre eux étaient atteints de
pathologies chroniques et nous avions
nous avons vécu également un manque de
médicaments liés à ces pathologies
chroniques qui serait à mon avis très
inquiétant enquête deuxième vague est ce
que ce risque de pénurie de médicaments
avaient été identifiés préalablement si
madame la présidente alors d'abord je
vais répondre à monsieur monsieur des
moulins bon l'utilisation des matchs de
bien porté ils concernent
essentiellement le ffp2 6e ffp2 c'est un
masque ici on veut qu'ils aient une
activité de filtration doit en même
temps est bien ajusté au visage et donc
c'est certainement celui mais c'est un
masque qui est porté par des
professionnels que l'on peut former
auquel on peut expliquer les choses
et donc je pense que le port du masque
ffp2 doit aller avec une sorte de deux
formations en revanche le port du masque
chirurgical qui est un masque anti
projections
finalement il faut essentiellement qui
couvrent la bouche et le nez
alors effectivement on en voit deux si
j'ose dire des vertes et des pas mûres
par exemple j'en ai vu porter le masque
sur la tête dans le métro dans
l'ensemble je trouve que les gens le
porte plutôt bien moi je prends le métro
tous les jours et je suis frappé de voir
que les gens portent bien le masque
chirurgical
il ya même des initiatives et c'est
étonnant j'étais à cotonou
dernier dans l'avion il y avait un
monsieur qui avait transformé son masque
pour les yeux en masque chirurgical qui
portait comme ça voyez donc il ya aussi
certains qui font preuve d'innovation
donc c'est un sujet très important mais
surtout pour le port du masque ffp2
alors ensuite concernant la réserve
sanitaire
je peux pas dire grand chose parce que
finalement j'ai pas je reçois les
bulletins j'ai lu les bulletins de santé
publique france willy mansion du nombre
de personnes mobilisées des actions qu
quelles sont elles sont conséquents qui
les concernent
mais je ne suis pas capable de porter un
jugement mon impression est qu'ils ont
un rôle par exemple en guyane j'ai
compris qu'ils avoir mobilisation de
d'une réserve pour la guyane ça me
paraît très bien et donc je je je pense
qu'il fera de manière très précise tirer
les leçons de l'utilisation de cette
réserve dans le cadre de cette crise
mais j'ai pas d'opinion personnelle sur
le sujet madame corneloup concernant la
le fait d'apprendre des d'apprendre des
épisodes
si vous voulez moi j'ai pas le souvenir
je parle de la période qui s'est
terminée pour moi en 2011 ce qui s'est
passé après je lis les journaux mais
j'ai pas de l'information vraiment très
très détaillé ce que je peux vous dit en
tout cas c'est que jusqu'en 2011 pour
l'acquisition des masses y avait pas de
problème budgétaire on était conscients
qu'il y avait un délai de péremption
qu'à un moment donné il allait falloir
les remplacer
madame vous avez mentionné cette
circulaire qui a enclenché le processus
pour les masques les plus anciens accès
achetés sans doute en 2003 2004 2005
2004 2005
voilà mais j'avoue que j'ai pas j'ai pas
de commentaire parce qu'après moi j'ai
perdu le fil d'aider le fil des choses
concernant de même concernant la
doctrine de 2013
il me semble qu'il ya un point très
important c'est que j'ai l'impression
que on a petit à petit disons
dévaloriser démonétisé l'intérêt du
masque ffp2 alors c'est un peu le coup
des raisins sont trop verts sire que
quand on veut effectivement considérer
qu'on n'a pas assez de masques ou con
veut pas en acheter on n'a qu'à dire
qu'ils sont pas très utiles
donc effectivement considérer que le
masque ffp2 il est réservé à des
professionnels de santé qui ne font que
quelques actes très invasif
moi ça me paraît excessif et je pense
que l'avis du haut conseil du 11 juillet
surtout pour un virus qui s'extrait
avant les symptômes
je pense qu'il faut avoir vis-à-vis des
professionnels de santé une approche
beaucoup plus active et j'aurais
tendance à leur mettre beaucoup plus
facilement que ça à disposition des
masques ffp2 et donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle il me semble que il ya une
responsabilité de l'état à acquérir des
stocks et à de masques ffp2 à
l'intention des professeurs je pense
qu'il n'est pas réaliste de considérer
que un établissement de santé
peut-être pas un très grand
établissement mais un établissement
normal ou un établissement médico social
soit capable de gérer dans la durée des
produits comme les masques ffp2 dans des
quantités importantes ça me paraît pas
dans la culture de ces établissements en
revanche ça me paraît dans la culture de
l'état à condition qu'ils soient
organisés pour bien faire pour bien
faire les choses donc de mon point de
vue j'aurais tendance à conseiller vous
parliez conseille de revenir sur stock
de masques chirurgicaux stocks de
masques ffp2 calcul des populations
civiles etc etc
il suffit peut-être de reprendre un peu
ce qu'on avait fait avant de avant 2011
les médicaments c'est la même chose moi
je me souviens très bien que justement
dans le cadre de la préparation à la
pandémie grippale
j'avais été discuté avec jean marimbert
le directeur de l'afssaps à ce moment là
en lui disant nous on veut pas se
retrouver pour des raison justement de
blocages de production etc
on avait fait la liste des médicaments
essentiels
cette liste des médicaments essentiels
elle a été l'existant on peut la
retrouver
est-ce qu'elle a été mise à jour je ne
sais pas mais il ya une liste des
médicaments essentiels et il me
semblerait extrêmement important de
partir de cette liste des médicaments
essentiels pour identifier où sont les
productions qui les produit et comment
on sécurise
alors nous on avait abordé le sujet non
pas tellement sous l'angle ça va être
bloqué en chine ou en inde mais plutôt
sous l'angle l'industrie pharmaceutique
du fait de l'absentéisme lié à la
pandémie risque plus être en capacité de
production donc organisez-vous pour
assurer la continuité de la production
c'était plutôt ça notre idée à ce moment
là et donc mais je pense qu'il faut voir
le sujet sous les deux angles continuité
de la production y compris des
entreprises en france et sécurisation
concernant les productions qui peuvent
être sur des territoires étrangers
merci beaucoup je pense que nous n'avons
plus de questions et je tenais à vous
remercier infiniment pour la précision
de vos réponses et en plus d'avoir
apporté les réponses à tous les
parlementaires donc un grand merci
voilà vous venez d'entendre didier
houssin s'exprimer devant les
parlementaires l'ancien directeur
général de la santé a indiqué qu'à son
départ
le stock stratégique de l'état s'évaluer
à un milliard de masques chirurgicaux et
700 millions de masques ffp2 une
déclaration qui laisse grande ouverte la
question de l'évaporation des stocks qui
s'en est suivi cette audition est à
retrouver sur notre site lci.fr